um is there advice
both small and big that you have for
somebody like me
the advice is to keep doing what feels
right to you
and do what you're doing obviously it's
resonating with people if you're getting
that big of an audience and i've
listened to your podcast you're very
good at it so
just keep doing it the way you're doing
it um don't let anybody else
get involved what about um you've
connected i think you met jamie at the
comedy store
i met him at the ice house at the ice
house well i think i met him at the
comedy store but then uh we talked
at the ice house i mean what you'd have
to ask him yeah did you think deeply
about
because like you know you basically have
nobody on your team
and and so it almost feels like a
marriage where is it
were you selective about like a jam to
somebody to bring into your little
circle
well jamie's exceptional he is he truly
is he's a special
i mean he might have grown i don't
remember how he was in the early days
maybe you could say but
he's definitely better at it but he
right away he's exceptional
he's uh got very little ego yes he's
he's not a guy who needs a lot of
attention he's not a guy
who um overestimates
uh anything like in terms of like
negative or positive like his uh like
his his uh
interpretation of whether it's uh
good things that happened to the show or
bad things that happen the show he just
takes it all like flat
he's chill he's just cool as [ __ ] and
he's so smart
and he's so good as an audio engineer
and as a podcast producer
he's the best but he's basically one of
the only people on on this whole team so
yeah how do you find i mean when you let
people in
i mean i'm sure other people wanted to
get involved like why don't you have a
co-host
like you basically kind of well you well
here's the problem with the co-host
like when you and i are talking when
we're talking
i'm tuned in to you and i'm waiting
to hear what you're saying and i'm
listening and i'm interpreting it
and then i'm calculating whether or not
i have anything to say
whether to let you keep talking whether
i maybe have a question that lets you
expand
further or whether i have a disagreement
or like there's a dance
that's going on now when there's another
person there chiming in too it [ __ ] the
dance up
it's like dancing like if you're doing
an uh a dance with someone
you know like if you're slow dancing
with someone and then a third person's
there
stepping on your feet sometimes it's fun
yeah
sometimes having a third person is fun
comedy podcast sometimes it's fun
um kind of structured yeah debate
structures but even then it gets
difficult because people talk over each
other and
also um i find that without headphones
it's way easier to talk over each other
you make mistakes
yeah you don't you don't hear it the
same way when you have headphones
you i hear what you hear it's all one
sound and i
the audience hears exactly
or rather i hear exactly what the
audience hears whether it's
over here my voice is louder than yours
because you're over there and if i don't
have headphones on it doesn't
it's not all together on that point one
of the interesting things about your
show
is uh you don't almost never have done
and you just generally don't do remote
like and
um sorry not remote calls but you don't
go to another person's location
like you have only done a few a small
handful and then just like
well the sapolsky he should be yeah he
should do this but actually
we went back and forth on email i told
him he needs to get your his ass back in
in in this in the studio uh he's working
on a book
i was a fan of his a long time ago
because i became obsessed with
toxoplasmosis
you know and i uh i've reached out to
him
a long time ago before he uh was willing
to do it but then
i caught him in downtown l.a he was
there for something else and i
just greedily snatched up an hour of his
time
well he doesn't get i think some of
those folks don't get how much magic can
happen in this podcast studio like
bigger than anything they've ever done
in terms of their work
not i'm not talking about reach but in
terms of the discovery of new ideas
there's something magical about
conversation like that
like somebody as brilliant as him if he
gives himself
over to the conversation for multiple
hours at a time
that's another place where you've been
inspiration where i
like you know i'm getting more and more
confidence of telling people
like an elon musk that like you know a
lot of ceos are like well
he has 30 minutes on his schedule i'm
like no
three hours so
and then they're like so some say no and
then they come back these people have
started coming back
to like okay we're starting to get it
they start to
get it and you're a rare beacon of hope
in that sense that there's some value in
long form
they think that nobody wants to listen
for 30 for more than 30 minutes
they think like i have nothing to say
but the reality is
if you just give yourself over to like
the three hours just let it go three
hours four hours whatever it is
there's so much to discover about what
you didn't even know you think
yeah yeah you have to be confident that
you could do it
and in the beginning i just did it
because that's what i wanted to do
and no one was listening so i've always
been a curious person so i've always
i've always
been interested in listening to how
people think about things and how
and talking to people about their
mindset and just
and expanding on my own ideas just
talking
[ __ ] and so we would have these podcasts
and they would go on forever and
my my friend arya i've i never let him
die and never let this die down i've let
him uh forget this he was always like
you have to edit your podcast i'm
telling you right now you're [ __ ] up
i go why he's like because people are
not going to listen to it i go they
don't have to
yeah i go you listen to part of it he
goes he goes just do it just i'm telling
you trust me
cut it down to like 45 minutes that's
all you need and i'm like no
no i don't think you're right i i like
listening to long form things no one
knows that kind of time
i go okay i'm going to do i'm just going
to keep doing it this way so
and it it sticks too good no he doesn't
listen
his are like two and a half hours long
now you
won but you wouldn't like say i
mentioned to you
before this is gonna happen it's
actually made a lot of progress towards
it i'm gonna
talk to putin but you wouldn't travel to
putin if you want to talk to you
putin is a dangerous character he's not
he's not you've talked to ever seen the
thing with jerry craft where they stole
his super bowl ring
yeah yeah those i think that was a
little bit of a misunderstanding
oh really i think it's a little bit he
just decided he's going to steal that
super bowl ring
kind of i think it was a behind him he
thought can i see your ring
he shows him his ring then he puts it on
says i can murder somebody with this
ring so he and then he walks off with it
it's possibly he did it
uh as a he's a big believer in displays
of power
yeah so like it's possible he did that
but on
i think he sees himself as like uh a
tool
with which to demonstrate that russia
still belongs on the stage of the big
players
and so he a lot of the action is
selected through that
lens but in terms of a human being
outside of any of the evils that uh he
may or may not have done
he is a really thoughtful intelligent
fun human being like the wit uh
and the depth from the jre perspective
is really interesting i'm like his
manager now selling
the he's a judo trying to get trump he's
really good at judo
he's i i have seen him practice judo
he's a legit black belt
and not only that he loves it not
just skill wise but to talk about it to
reason about it to think about it
to mma as well so yeah maybe
it'd be a good conversation but you
wouldn't travel to him
[Laughter]
well this holds your principle so that's
the core of the advice
or whatever i would rather here's the
thing
there's not a person that i have to have
on the show right
and i'm happy to talk to anybody i'm
just as happy to talk to you
as i am to talk to trump as i am
probably more happy to talk to you
as i am to talk to mike tyson as i am to
talk to joey diaz i like talking to
people
i enjoy doing podcasts i enjoy talking
to a variety of people
and i schedule them based on i want to
like i try not to get too many right
wing people in a row
or too many progressive people in a row
i don't want to get repetitive
trying to get too many fighters in a row
i try to balance it out not too many
comedians
comedians are the one one group where i
can have three four in a row five in a
row because that's my tribe
you know those are my people it's easy
we could talk about anything
it's a weird dance you know the
conversations that you're doing on a
podcast are
there they're a strange dance and you
want to
you know you want to not step on your
own feet and you want to make sure that
you
do it in a way do the podcast in a way
that's entertaining for people and
it's it's the conversations are learning
how to
talk to me it's a weird skill yeah it's
a weird skill that took a long time for
me to get good at and i didn't know it
was a skill until i started doing it
and then i i just thought you're just
talking like i was just i know how to
talk we'll just talk to people
and then along the way i realized like
oh and then when you talk to people that
are bad at it
you realize that it's a skill like
particularly
one of the things about my people about
comedians is
a lot of them tend to want to talk but
don't want to listen
right so they're they're waiting for you
to stop talking so they can talk but
they're not necessarily thinking about
what you're saying
you know and they're just they're just
waiting for their opportunity or they
talk over you or they
and i try real hard not to do that and
sometimes i fail but
my when i'm at my best i'm
i'm dancing yeah ultimately the skill
conversation is just
really listening mm-hmm like really and
listening and thinking
listening and thinking and being like
genuinely curious
and and really having um uh you know
a take on what they're saying and and uh
maybe a follow-up question or maybe you
know just got it it's got to be real
it's got to be authentic
and when it is authentic and it's real
it resonates with people like they're
listening and they go
oh like i'm locked in with the way
you're thinking
like you two guys are in a conversation
and i'm locked in
you know when she talks and you listen
i'm listening to
you know when he says something to her
when she says something to
to him like there's a thing that happens
during conversations where
you're there like you're listening to
and it's
with me when i listen to a good podcast
i feel like i'm in the room
i feel like i'm in the room and i'm like
like i'm i'm like the friend that got to
sit down and listen
like oh yeah it's a great conversation
yeah you know
i love conversations so i love listening
to them and i love putting them together
and
the fact that this podcast has gotten so
[ __ ] big
it it's stunning to me it blows me away
no i never anticipated it
never thought for a second that that
stupid thing that i used to do in my
couch
in my my office was the biggest thing
i've ever done in my life
by far like people used to make fun of
it like there's a comedy store
documentary that's coming out
and one of the parts of the
documentaries my friend tom segura
when he first started doing my podcast
he would he would be leaving and he
would talk to red band he's like what
the [ __ ] is he doing yeah like why is he
doing this like
who's listening he's like oh some people
like it yeah and he's like
[ __ ] nonsense waste of time and like
in the
the documentary it shows like 2 000
views like one of the early ustream
episodes hilarious and they don't just
like it really
they uh they form a friendship with you
it's like
even me when people come up to me like
the love in their eyes is kind of
beautiful
weird right yeah it's like you're part
of their life yeah and it
i don't know it's all it's also
heartbreaking because
you realize you'll never really get to
know them back
like because they they clearly are
friends with you
yes yeah and it's sad to see a person
who's clearly brilliant and interesting
and
is friends with you but you don't get a
chance to return
that love and does i mean my kids it
took them a while to figure out what's
going on
but uh people come up to me and uh
you know they would say something like
hey man i [ __ ] love you thanks man
all right hey brother nice to meet you
my daughter was like sick she'd be like
do you know him
yeah i'm like no i don't know him she's
like how does he know you
it's a very weird conversation i used to
have with
young kids when i'd explain i do this
thing called the podcast and
millions of people listen so now one of
my daughters is 12
and one of her friends is 13 and he's a
boy and he goes to school with her and
he's obsessed with me
and so she's weirded out and she says to
him i don't think you like me i think
you're just into my dad you [ __ ]
weirdo
she's going to have that conversation in
a few stages in her life
oh that's that hard conversation with a
boyfriend yeah
probably yeah that was the thing about
men too
this this podcast um is uh
my podcast is uniquely masculine i'm a
man
and i'm not i i'm also a man that
doesn't have to go through some sort of
a corporate filter
i'm not going through executive
producers who tell me
don't don't have this guest on don't
talk about that
you know that we looked at focus groups
and they don't they don't seem to like
when you do this
like there's none of that i just and i i
i just do it
so if that's so i have a whole podcast
where i just talk about cars
and people like i don't want to hear you
talk about cars well good
congratulations
you found what you like here's good news
there's 1500 other ones
go listen to the other episodes where i
don't talk about cars you know you don't
have to listen
and it's not like your brand you just
are who you are and that's what you do
but it's like it's authentically
what i'm interested in all the podcasts
whether i'm talking
to david fravor about his experience
with ufos whether i'm talking to
david sinclair about life extension
whether i'm talking to you about
artificial intelligence or what it's
because i
want to talk to these people and that
that resonates i i like when people are
into [ __ ]
you know i've talked about this before
like things that i have no interest in
making furniture
but i like this pbs show where this guy
makes furniture by hand
yeah i love watching it craftsman
because he's so into it yeah he's
extending this
and polishing that i'm not going to do
that i don't give a [ __ ] about furniture
furniture for me is function like this
desk function it works
but i love when people are into it you
know and i'm happy that someone can make
it and they do a great job
but i'm not i'm not interested in the
the task is or the even the finished
product as much as i'm interested in
someone's passion for something the
passion that they've put into this
that shines through last question
i sometimes ask this just for to uh
what is it to challenge to make people
roll their eyes
to make legitimate scientists roll their
eyes ask
what is the meaning of life according to
joe rogan i do not think there is a
meaning
i think there's many many meanings of
life i think there's a way to navigate
life that's enjoyable
i think it requires many things it
requires first of all requires love
you have to have loved ones you have to
have family you have to have friends
you have to have people that care about
you and you have to care about them
i think that is primary then it also
requires
interests there has to be things that
stimulate you
now it could be just a subsistence
lifestyle there's many people that
believe
and practice this uh lifestyle of just
living off the land and hunting and
fishing and living in the woods
and they seem incredibly happy yeah and
there's there's something to be said for
that
that is an interest right there's
something and there's a there's a
direct connection between their actions
and their sustenance
they get their food that way they're
connected to nature and it's very
satisfying for them
if you don't have that uh i think you
need something that
is interesting to you something that
you're passionate about
and there's far too many people that get
sucked into living a life where
you're just doing a job you're just
showing up and putting in your time and
then going home but you don't have a
passion
for what you're doing and i think that
is that's the recipe for a boring
and very unfulfilling life you mentioned
love difficult
backtrack what uh we talked about the
demons and the violence
in there somewhere what's the role of
love in this
in your own life it's very important man
and that's one of the reasons why i'm so
uh i'm so interested in helping people
i'm very interested in people feeling
good
i like them to feel good i want to help
them i like i like doing things that
make them feel like oh you care about me
like yeah i care about you
i really do like i want people to feel
good i want
my family to feel good i want my friends
to feel good i want guests to feel
good about the podcast experience you
know i i
am i'm a big believer in as much as i
can to spread
positive energy and joy and happiness
and and relay all the good advice that
i've ever gotten
all the things that i've learned and if
they can benefit people and i find that
those things benefit people
and actually improve the quality of
their life or improve their success
or improve their relationships or i'm
very happy to do that
that means a lot to me the the way we
interact with each other is
so important it's one of the reasons why
i like if someone gets cancelled
or you get publicly shamed it's so
devastating because there's all these
people that
negative all this negative energy coming
your way and you feel it as much as you
like to pretend that you
you're immune to that kind of stuff and
some people do like to pretend that
you feel it there's a there's a tangible
force
when people are upset at you and that's
the same with loved ones
or family or anytime someone's upset at
you
whether it's a giant group of people or
there's a small amount of people
that has an impact on you and your
psyche
and your physical being so the more you
can
spread love and the more love comes back
to you
you also create this butterfly effect
right because where
other people start recognizing like oh
you know when he is nice to me
i feel better and then i'm going to be
nicer to people and when i'm nicer to
people they feel better and i feel
better and
and it spreads outward and that's one
thing that i've done through this
podcast i think is i've
i've imparted my personal philosophy on
in in kindness and generosity to other
people yeah i mean
to correct you you didn't do it the
ideas that are breeding themselves
through your brain have figured out the
ideas
that are alive in the air made their way
into my head
love is a more efficient mechanism of
spreading ideas they figured out
yes probably man
probably um so as far as like
uh the meaning of life that's that's a
bit without that you have nothing
you know one of the big biggest failures
in life is to be extremely successful
financially but everybody hates you
everybody hates you and you're just
miserable and alone and angry and
depressed and sad
you know when you you hear about rich
famous people that commit suicide
wow you missed the mark you got
some parts right but you put too many
eggs in one basket
you put too many eggs in the financial
basket or the success basket or the
accomplishment basket
and not enough in the friendship and
love basket and there's a balance to
that
and when i talked about the violence and
all that stuff like
that to me is me understanding
recognizing that is me trying to achieve
that balance
it's so like go kill those demons so
that this boat is level
you know because if it's not then the
boat is like this and then everything's
all [ __ ] up and every time we hit a
wave things fall apart
balance that boat out figure it out like
know who you are
some people don't have that problem at
all some people they could just go for
walks and they're cool as a cucumber
i need more you know i need kettlebells
i need a heavy bag
i need uh i need the echo bike you know
air assault bike
i need some hardcore [ __ ] and if i don't
get that i don't feel good
so i figured that out too and that makes
me a nicer person and that makes my
interactions nicer it makes
it it changes the quality of my
my friendships and my relationships with
people i think
uh we mentioned eurolink i can
i can certainly uh guarantee that this
is one of the memories i'll be replaying
20 30 years from now once we get the
feature ready joe it's a huge honor to
talk
to you i hope it's an honor to talk to
you too man dude i just came down here
for this
the first week of me doing this here and
it's uh
it's it's very cool to have you always i
hope you make uh texas
cool again and uh and and uh do your
podcast another 10
11 whatever however many years you're
still on this earth all right thank you
brother
appreciate you man thanks for listening
to this conversation with joe rogan
and thank you to our sponsors neuro
asleep
and dollar shave club check them out in
the description to get a discount and
to support this podcast if you enjoy
this thing subscribe on youtube
review it with 5 stars on apple podcast
follow on spotify
support on patreon or connect with me on
twitter lex friedman
and now let me leave you with some words
of wisdom from joe rogan
the universe rewards calculated risk
and passion thank you for listening and
hope to see you
next time